どうも皆さんこんにちは天才料理研究家秋
といえば食欲の秋食欲草の掃除し之です皆
さんは秋といえば何を彷彿させます
でしょうかま人によってはスポーツの秋
だったり読書の秋そしてこの秋といえば
やはり食欲の秋ではないでしょうかま
こんな季節ですね特に美味しいと言われて
いるのがキノコ類えのき舞茸シなどが
とても美味しい季節でござい
ます私キノコ苦手です今日はですねそんな
キノコなどを使った秋にですね是非とも皆
様に食べていただきたい悪魔的なメニュー
をご紹介したいと思いますこれねすごいん
ですよ食材こちらに並んでるんですけれど
もキノコが苦手な僕でもはまっちゃうん
じゃないかみたいな私がこれ食べれたら皆
さんは絶対食べれますし美味しいって
感じること間違いなしそして悪魔的なメニ
になってるのでもリピートしちゃうわけ
ですよキノコ苦手でも美味しく食べられる
そんな悪魔的メニュー今回三子なご用意
いたしましたので早速作っていき
ましょう食べれるよ
ねはいというわけで早速1品目のメニュー
作っていきましょう最初に作るのは
炊き込みご飯でございます好きな人
たくさんいらっしゃるのではないでしょう
かなんと調理時間10分10分以内で
作れる簡単メニューなのであまり普段料理
しないなっていう方でも楽しく簡単に
作れることができると思いますでは材料
紹介していきましょうお米2薄切りになっ
た豚バラ肉を240gシジ大きめ1パック
ぐらい200gエリンギ1パック100g
程度ニンニクを1玉お塩少々そして密缶味
ポンを100ml黒コショを適量準備して
くださいでは早速作っていきましょう
レッツクッキーイザダークネスまずお米を
お水で研いでいき
[音楽]
ますで入れていきます炊飯機の容器に
ザザッと移しこれをそのまま炊飯器に入れ
ずにまずお水を入れて洗っていきましょう
米を研いでいき
[音楽]
ますあってますよね1回水切ると白くなっ
てき
[音楽]
たらすいませんねあの僕助手がたくさんい
てコメトグとかそういう家庭いつも助手に
やらせてるんであんまり私自体やんないん
ですよねこういう米研ぎとかは前がよかお
米研ぎ終わりましたこのままお水入れます
お水2号分入れたいんですけれども後から
味ポを追加するのでちょっと少なめにお水
入れていきますでお水入れていきますお水
もねこれ美味しいお水使ってますからね
入れ
[音楽]
ますこれこれぐらいかな1.565分
ぐらいまで入れてみました
[音楽]
次は豚肉切っていきましょう一口サイズ
ぐらいに切れればオッケーでございます
一口サイズって何枚か重ねて切っちゃった
あわかりました豪快に何枚か重ねて切っ
ちゃいます豪快にはい何枚か重ねました
これで一口サイズに切っていきたいと思い
ますいき
[音楽]
ますふふんふん
デリシャス合ってますよね一口サイズ一口
サイズおら
合ってんのかこれさ包丁使う時は安全に
切りましょうね私ほどのシェフになれば
やはりちょっと普通だの人とは違う使い方
になっちゃうので危ない包丁の使い方は
真似をしないようにお願いいたしますと
いうわけで豚肉切り終わりました一口
サイズでございます次に今切ったこの豚肉
にちょっと塩を軽くまぶしていきましょう
味付けでございますでお塩まぶしていき
たいと思い
[音楽]
ます
こう全体的に塩が生き渡るようにしっかり
と練り込んでいきましょうで次ですキノコ
切っていき
ましょうこれですよねえ俺ちょっとあの
触るのも怖いんだよないい意味でうわ
こわ人生って初キノコ触ります多分これ
触っていいんですか集合体恐怖所なん
でしょうねきっと私なんかすごい怖いです
キノコの根元の方切っていきたいと思い
ます行きますね
ほうえこれもうちょっといきますか
う
[音楽]
うわううもうもいいかなもういいですかね
できましたできまし
[音楽]
たうわであのキノコは適量使っていき
ましょうキノコ好きな方はたくさん入れて
もいいでしょうしキノコの入れる量はあの
個人の自由だと思います私は少なめでいき
ますじゃ次はエリン行きます
[音楽]
まず根元を切ります
ううこれでいいんですかねもちい根元切り
ますどういう素材だこれで咲いていきます
う避けるんだキノコって
すごいうわすごい人生初やんあそうでも
ないです
けどこんな感じですよねでもなんかこの
直接キノコに触れ合うことによって
ちょっと苦手意識が今若干減ってきつつ
ありますはいこれぐらいにしましょうでは
続いてニンニク切っていきましょうなんと
このメニュー豪快にニンニクを使います横
にしてこのままもスパンといっちゃい
ますパったやばい人生って1番硬い
ぞはいはいオケオオケ切れましたでなんと
ニンニクこのまま豪快に皮をむかず入れて
いきますこれで食材の準備ができたので
ご飯に各食材を入れていきたいと思います
では入れていきましょうまずお肉バーン
きのこニンニク皮ご入れちゃいますはい
全て入れましたそしてご飯を炊く前に味
ポンをこの中に入れていきます2号ぐらい
にしたいのでま2号ちょっとぐらいかな
入れていき
ましょううわうまそう色がもう
めちゃくちゃ鮮やか
はい入れ終わりましたそしてこれを炊飯器
で炊いていき
ましょう
おできまし
たというわけで炊き込みご飯できまし
たあやばい飛ぶニンニクの香りが
めちゃくちゃ効いててマジで美味しそう
ですでお肉が今固まってたりニンニクの皮
が入ってるので1回それ取り除いていき
ましょううわニンニクも超柔らかくなっ
てるこれ悪魔的やなこれすごいなマジで
美味しそうだな皮全部取れましたのであと
はお肉がまになるようにちょっとかき混ぜ
ていきますかき混ぜていき
ますこれこれやばい
なよし結構いい感じなのではないでしょう
かあとは盛り付けて完成
[音楽]
ですさあ続いてのメニューは誰でも簡単に
作れます柔らかシュなんとフライパンで
簡単に作れます是非お試しください材料
こちらになり
ます豚バラ肉のブロックを1kg長ねぎ
ゆで卵2個茸を1パック約100gずつに
なりますコーラ3つ缶味ポンお好みで
おろしニンニクおろし生姜をご準備
くださいでは早速作っていきたいと思い
ますじゃまずはえっと豚肉切っていきます
ま2kgぐらいあるのでこれを半分に切っ
ていく感じですね切ります
なかなかこんな大きい豚肉のブロックも見
ないから
なおかてえやばいピザより硬いぞこれピザ
ローラー持ってきてもらって買ってきます
よしいけたかと思いますこれでちょうど
半分ですね使うのは半分だけになります
このお肉に塩で味付けしていきますま大体
で大丈夫
ですですり込んでいき
ます裏も行き
ましょう
白胡椒もかけていき
ましょううんオッケーだと思います次に
豚肉に焼き目をつけていきます先ほど準備
した豚肉をフライパンに乗せていきます
れファイヤー両面焼きたいのでちょっと
こうひっくり返しながらやっていき
ましょうやばいなんかじ言ってるもうこれ
ひっくり返していいのかなこれ
ひっくり返してまだですなんかホット
ケーキのしてきたあまだ全然大丈夫そう
ですねもうちょいかなあた嘘です演技
[音楽]
ですそろそろどうでしょうあ結構いい色に
なってるではひっくり返し
[音楽]
ますよしよしよしよしよしわうまそうよし
よしいい
ぞどうかな
あ結構いいんじゃないでしょうか1回
ひっくり返ししてみますよいしょうわ
すごいあとこの側面横の方も焼いていき
ましょう熱い助けて誰か危なよしよしよし
よしどうでしょうどうでしょうあつあー
どうでしょうこれであの両方焼けると思い
ますこれでチシはオッケーです次に調味料
とネギを入れていきたいと思い
ますっバン姜バンこれがマヨネーズにん
ニンニバンそしてアジポンとコーラで引き
さしていきましょう全部入れてきます
おらうわ
すごいこれ豪快にも全部入れていき
ましょうすごい
ぞよしよしよしよしよし美味しくなあれ
おいしくなあれはい全部入れ終りましたで
最後にお蓋を上に置きます
はいこれであとは味が染み込むまで放置し
て完成まで待ちましょうはいというであれ
からちょっと表よりは変えながらなんです
けど450分ぐらい熱しましたちょっと
開けてみましょうかどうなってるん
でしょう取ってみ
ますうわあ
すげえ家でチャーシュって作れるんだ
すごいなも色がめっちゃ美味しそうなんだ
けど何これ
あチャーシュですで最後にですねこっち
こちら舞茸と卵をこの中に入れて少しまた
熱して完成です
よいしょうわあこれ味つくんだろうなよし
うわあこれでしばらく熱して完成
です
[音楽]
うわあうわうま
そうはいというわけでチャーシュ完成し
まし
た色で分かる美味しいですこれ卵も
しっかり味が染み込んでまいたけもかなり
味が染み込んでそうでもう本当に食べるの
が楽しみですさあ続いてのメニューに行き
ましょう次は天津飯を作っていきたいと
思い
ます実初ですちょどうやって作っていくの
でしょうか材料はこちらですご飯お茶碗2
杯分卵2個カニ風味かまぼこ2本お砂糖
大さじ1杯えのき1パック50gおろし
生姜少々小ねぎ適量サラダ油を炒めように
大さじ2杯アを作る時に必要な蜜缶の味
ポン大さじ3杯片栗粉小さじ1杯お水
1/2カップ鶏ガラスープの元小さじ1杯
じゃ早速作っていきたいと思いますでは
まずカニカマをさえていきます天津飯に
乗ってる感じってことすよねこれぐらいか
な小さすぎてもちょっと
ね分かりづらいので料理の中で視聴できる
ぐらいの太さでいい気がします
オッケーです次は次は切りですこれまず
切っていきましょう根元切りますうわ
なんか今生きてたこれ生きてます切り
[音楽]
ますうはいうわーすごい断面
だばしみたいさらに3分割ぐらいにして
いきます
よいしょよいしょちょっとずつに慣れてき
ましたねでまえのきをなんか気持ち
程度使いますはいというわけで次はアンを
作っていきたいと思いますでまず水入れて
いき
ますお
砂糖味
ポン鶏ガラスープの
素
えのきはいはいはい片栗粉片栗粉は少し
ずつ入れていきましょうダになってしまい
ますよしこれであとは火をつけますそう
するととろみが出る
はずわあなんかちょっととろみが出てき
てる気がするなもうちょっと片栗粉入れ
ますうんああちょっととろっとしてきたか
なこれで火を止め
ますわあめっちゃア
だ天津犯のアができました
感動ええこうやってできるんだ次に天津飯
の卵の部分作っていきたいと思いますまず
卵を割り
[音楽]
ます2つ割り
ましょう何が何でも片手でやりたい
カニカマ入れていき
ます生姜る混ぜていき
ますうわうまそううんいいのじゃない
でしょうかでかき混ぜた卵をフライパンで
熱していきますここがすごい大事なん
でしょうね油をかけていきます
全体に行き渡らせますでは卵入れていき
ますいきますファイヤ
らはいはいはい程よくね程よく
その程よくでいいんですっ
てはいはいはいはいはいはいどうでしょう
どう
でしょうもうちょっと混ぜます
ねはいこれくらいいくかなちょマジで
わからんでもどうでしょうかこんなぐらい
でオッケーですかねこれでオッケーでした
じゃ最後卵をご飯に乗せますスライドして
バンて乗せたいってことでなこんなことが
可能なんだろうかこの僕にいけ
[音楽]
うわあ
ギリセーフで最後さっき作ったアをかけて
完成ですでかけていき
ます
うわあこれですねでは最後ネギを乗せて
完成
ですあしまし
[音楽]
たというわけで完成しましたちょっと卵を
乗せるのが若干下手だったんですけども
こちら天心犯でございます人生で初めて
作りましたいやもっとうまく卵乗せれ
たかったんですけどもこれは多分練習が
やりますねはいというわけでサピできまし
たまさか人生でシャーシ展示販作る日が
来るとは思いもしま
いつも通り美味しく作れましたでは早速秋
の味覚いただきたいと思いますいただき
ますまずは炊き込みご飯からいただき
ましょうえキノコ入ってたんだよなそれが
ちょっと唯一引っかかる部分でありますが
苦手な私でも美味しく食べれるのでしょう
かいただき
ます匂いやべえニンニクが本当にこれ
やばいないただき
[音楽]
ます
ああやばいわキノコ入ってるのにうまい
アポの味もすごい効いててあとニンニクも
入れることによってなんか中毒性あります
ねこれいやあ悪魔的に美味しい炊き込み
ご飯とても美味しいですメメし
ましょう中毒車続出2度と抜け出せ
ないインフィニティループ炊き込みご飯で
ござい
ますこれは一生秋が巡って欲しいとなって
しまいますね忘れられない味になりますほ
冗談抜きでこれだけ食べ続きたいんです
けれども他の秋の味覚も楽しんでいき
ましょうじゃ次チャーシュ食べてみたいと
思いますチャーシュいただき
[音楽]
ますうまなんて表現したらいいんだろう
コーラとアポンですねこれ多分決め手は
甘くてすごい食べ
やすいううまやばい口の中がトロトロに
なりますねちょっと卵をいただきます味が
染めてて美味しそうです
ねいや美味しいなてかアジポンってすごい
な何にでも合いますねご飯作る時アジポン
に合う料理ってすごい多いのでちょっと
これ料理が正直苦手なんす
よ天才料理研究がです料理苦手な僕でも
ですねちょっと使いこなせそうなアポン
すごいですねんいろんな料理に本当に使え
そうですバのもうなんかトロっとした
チャーシューがとても美味しくてこれも
無限に食べれれそうです命名します
トミティインフィニティ
ダイバーシティーチャーシュービックリ
マック4
つじゃ最後にこちらの天神犯いただきたい
と思います初めて作ったわこんなの
ちょっとキノコたくさんありますが食べて
みたいと思いますではいただき
[音楽]
ます
うまこれ多分アジポンですねアポンで酸味
が効いててなんか食欲が止まんなくなる
タイプの味ですねなんかすっきりしてるん
だよね味
があやばい本当そまなくになるいや
美味しい素晴らしいです命名しますこちら
の天心
飯天井がドソ業無新天津犯
ですもう天津犯より美味しいんですねこれ
なんだろうこの若干の酸味というかなんか
すごい爽やかというか普通の天神ガの
ちょっとこのなんかだるとした感じが
キュッと引き締められてめちゃくちゃ食べ
やすいです3つも最高に美味しかったです
はいというわけで今回ですねいろんな料理
作ってみたんですけれども全てのメニに
使われていますこちらのアジポンこれが
ないと今回の料理は作れませんでした最高
に美味しかったですありがとうございます
はいというわけでですね今みつかんさんが
旬の食材を美味しく食べる瞬ごち
プロジェクトというものに取り組んでおり
ますそしてとこの動画が出た後から10月
末から私はじめ社長プレゼンツのSNSで
の投稿キャンペーンも始まりますでなんか
そのキャンペーンでですねなんとこういう
のも当たるっぽいですよ見てアポンじゃ
なくてハジポンなんですよごめんなさい
これあの僕が考えたんですけどもえかけ
たいものにぶっかけろサラダ餃子大根
おろし発の叩きだと思うとあのかなり
ふざけたパッケージになってますハジポン
これアジポンさんに作っていただきました
ありがとうございますこういうのも当たり
ますそしてなんとこのキャンペーンに当選
された方は私はじめ社長が発表させて
いただきますので皆さん是非参加してみて
ください詳しくは動画の概要欄から
チェックしてみてくださいいやもうほと
アポン作ったら何でも美味しくなるんか
なって思ってます僕は今それくらいもう
なんか食を楽しむためには必品ですねアジ
ポンはぜひ皆さんアポン使って色々
美味しくご飯を食べてみましょう
[音楽]
Z